Good evening. I hope you're all there
and can hear me. Welcome to this
Halloween special
dealing with Count Dracula.
Um,
all right, let's get to it. I hope you
can see and hear me, but we'll find out.
I'm usually just being paranoid. All
right, I see a comment saying we're
live. I think that means you can see and
hear me. Good. All right, let's do it.
All right, so thanks for joining me.
It's um Halloween week. And um I figured
I'd talk about something that is
relevant to it, namely the king of all
spooks, Dracula, because I actually know
a thing or two about him, the real
Dracula. and the fake Dracula. And it's
actually going to make for a very
interesting um discussion to figure out
what it's all really about going on with
Hollywood, you know, the fake fictitious
Dracula, the real Dracula, how they
coincide, and what it all means,
especially in the context of Halloween.
Um, so actually, let's start with a few
words about Halloween.
Um, I guess to most of us, you grow up
in America and Halloween's just a time
where people scare each other, play
games, and kids go around begging for
treats or something.
Uh, I think I went I did it one time
when I was a kid and I was very very
young and my um immigrant Coptic
paranoid mother of course convinced me
when I came home that all the candies
that I had gotten had razor blades in
them. So, I didn't really eat or we
actually had to go through them
meticulously. But hey, that does happen.
It was a good point. At any rate, let's
discuss the real Halloween or how we
know it. And of course, to those in the
know, Halloween is uh a Christian
holiday. Okay, look at the very words.
It's made up of two words. Hallowed,
like hallowed be thy name, you know, to
make something holy. And uh the second
part, the ein, I believe doing quick
research, that's sort of the Scottish or
maybe a Gaelic kind of pronunciation for
evening because Halloween is the night
before All Saints Day, another Christian
holiday that venerates and obser and and
remembers saints, holy people, which is
on November 1st. Um and we know all this
in fact because a pope I think in the
9th century uh dedicated a chapel to all
the saints in St. Peter's Basilica and
that and and the the dedication date
which was November 1st became the day
that all saints are remembered.
So the night before the hallowed evening
of before is today our Halloween.
And uh don't ask me how it got to become
what it is today. I mean there's various
theories of course uh a lot of pagan
pre-Christian sorts of things that uh
wormed their way in. The theories I
remember coming across uh one is that
people would dress in scary guises in
order to keep scary evil spirits away.
Another one actually does kind of
include little kids and and going around
looking for candy and whatnot. But
anyway, it finally morphed into what it
is today.
which is uh sadly something not even for
little kids as much as anymore as
grown-ups really enjoy it and apparently
enjoy getting dressed up and I guess
what they really want to be and okay I'm
going to stop right there before I
really start going off track. So anyway,
so that's Halloween and I think it's
important I had to just preface
everything by talking about it. So, now
let's look at the paragon of Halloween,
the guy who I think everyone associates
with Halloween more than anyone else,
the spook, the monster, and that of
course would be Count Dracula.
I mean, I'm sure there's close seconds,
you know, maybe the witch flying in a
broom, the mummy, whatnot. Uh, all of
these, I suppose, are contenders, but I
think for me, Count Dracula, you ever
see that uh in the 80s, the Halloween
that almost wasn't? It's pretty funny
actually. It was a little I think it was
like a short TV program and it was all
the monsters meeting together and
because Halloween someone was going to
cancel Halloween and it turned out to be
the witch because she was upset that the
king of the monsters who was Dracula
wasn't sharing power with her. But
anyway, I only bring that up because it
kind of again underscores the idea that
the vampire, the Dracula is the king of
Halloween.
All right, so who is this Dracula? Let's
actually start off with the fake
Dracula. The Dracula that we do that
everyone seems to know, Count Dracula,
the monster. And I think, you know, what
we're going to look at here is the sort
of evolution of the real Dracula,
Flatpish, the Romanian warlord or Void.
We'll talk about him a lot. And um how
he served to create the fictitious
Dracula that we know. And then how that
Dracula has also continued to morph and
change into the modern era which I also
find pretty fascinating. I think you
will too for the the reasons that we
will uh get into.
All right. So the fake Dracula all
begins. It's a novel. I actually have it
here. I actually read it. Well, this
isn't I mean this is called the library
of classic horror stories, but it
although most of it is Count Dracula
because it's very long and I read that
maybe over like 25 30 years ago,
which means I had to look up what Count
Dracula is all about again because I had
forgotten. And uh but as I read about
it, I I I started remembering things
about it.
And uh and by the way, one of my pet
peeves that I have and I'm going to
share it with you because it's actually
very relevant when it comes to reading.
I think I might have said this before in
my live stream about reading but uh and
this is another perfect example. So I
read this book Count Dracula Bram Stoker
literally 25 maybe 30 years ago. So,
okay, give me, you know, obviously you
can't expect me to remember everything.
But, um, since then, of course, I've
been privy to all sorts of movies,
shows, whatever. That deal with vampire,
that deal with Dracula. Um, you know,
most notably, Bram Stoker's Dracula,
which is actually named after the
author, that's the most famous, I think,
Dracula, which I've watched quite a
number of times, and I think it's
actually a good movie overall. Okay. It
was made in the 90s, I believe. I just
like it primarily for Anthony Hopkins, I
think. But anyway, um my point is that
here's another perfect example of you
you read a book and you embibe it and
you absorb it and it's in your mind and
then you watch movies and adaptations
about books and then when then years
later when you start stop and try to
think about the book only images from
the movie pop in and I completely forgot
the book. Uh, I I think I might have
talked about this before with like Lord
of the Rings where I've read the books,
but then I watch the movies and then
before you know it, I don't when I think
of Lord of the Rings, I just get scenes
out of the movies which are not
necessarily even in the book. All right,
that was just a little detour um that I
just had to get out there. another
another uh you know call to actually
read more and watch less because one
will always supplant the other and you
don't want Hollywood supplanting and
having the final word over books. All
right, enough said. So, let's get into
it. So, Bram Stoker wrote his book uh
his novel Count Dracula. I believe it I
wrote it I discussed this in my book
Defenders of the West. I think it came
out in 1894 is when he wrote it. And um
so he based it basically uh and it comes
it's written in it's actually written in
a nice way. It's like di it's realistic.
It's written in diaries and letters and
you know um it gives it sort of a
realistic v veneer. And that's kind of
what he he was going for. Obviously
that's what a good novelist would do.
And part of that, of course, is he
wanted to give it a a realistic setting
and even possibly ground it in someone
or a historical figure who could
somehow, you know, feed into the idea of
Count Dracula. So, having done a a few
uh Okay, actually the book came out in
1897. See, I wrote it down here and I'm
just going off the top of my head now,
you know, 1897.
And um and he wrote the book. So
basically he did like very easy research
and uh he came across a writing about a
guy named Draul Dracula and he learned
that he was pretty vicious and violent
and he lived somewhere in that region.
He was he was wakian but anyway he
placed it in Transylvania which is
somewhere up north of Wakia. Um and you
know he got the story and the story just
to summarize spoiler alert you know in
the book and which is also in a lot of
the movies you get this guy Jonathan
Harker who's from you know he's English
and he goes to Transylvania because some
count wants to purchase properties and
he's there and he goes and then he finds
before long he he realizes this is a
vampire and he gets trapped but
eventually escapes but in the meantime
Dracula makes it to the to England and
uh he starts praying on these people who
are close to Jonathan Harker especially
two women. One would be uh Jonathan's
fiance, I think Mia, and then the other
one, Lucy, who he basically starts
sucking on and killing eventually very
early on. And he he tries to do the same
thing with Lucy. Um or I'm sorry, Mia.
And then um but then Harker is back,
Jonathan Harker, and he meets up with
Van Helsing, I think, the Anthony
Hopkins figure in that movie at least.
Um, and they all uh they figure out he's
a vampire and then the hunt begins to
kill Dracula or to stop him somehow. And
uh well and eventually they do they they
succeed.
Um now what's really interesting is
let's actually first start talking about
the differences between what Bram Stoker
wrote and what we know today. Okay. So
actually if you read the book by and
it's a good book I mean from what I
recall uh you know Bram Stoker's novel
it's much better than the movies but if
you read it what you're going to be
struck with is that so let's let's
compare with the movie you're familiar
let's say with um the Bram Stoker movie
'90s one that I was referring to the
most famous one I think and I would
argue a lot of it is very accurate it's
very based on the book which is what
makes it more troubling because the more
act the the closer it is to the book and
then it has just a few things off, the
more your mind is prone to absorbing it
as the real thing. Anyway, so it's very
accurate, but where does it veer off?
All right, it veers off in this sense.
First, Dracula in the book, in the
novel, is a disgusting figure. Not in
any way, shape, or form sympathetic.
He's literally a monster. Okay. He's not
something that anyone finds appealing.
Nor is nor does he have some sort of
unrequitted love that he's trying to
rekindle. Okay. He's literally a monster
that needs to feed on blood. Pretty
hideous, physically repulsive the way
he's described. Okay. And um now in the
movies, we don't get that, do we?
Dracula tends to be kind of a suave,
hip, kind of an aristocrat, uh, kind of
sexy as it were. Um, right. That's not
in the book. You know what? And another
another book and movie that just came
into my mind that's very similar because
I read it is uh, man, what's it called?
The one with a Oh, Phantom of the Opera.
If you watch the movie or the play or
it's it's a musical, you know, you know
the one that came out in the 2000s.
If you watch that one, he's he's a
sympathetic kind of hands, very
handsome. I mean, he's a little
disfigured, but he's a handsome,
romantic kind of guy. In the actual
book, The Phantom of the Opera is just
another a monstrosity. Nothing
whatsoever sympathetic or appealing
about him, nor is he even romantic.
Okay. So, so it's interesting to see
that these books, that's how they
present these guys. And then in the
movies, they're, you know, they're
always sympathetic. They're
misunderstood. They're just, you know,
they're just looking for love. Okay.
Yeah. Interesting stuff. But anyway,
back to Dracula.
So, total monstrosity. Number one,
Dracula. Number two, um, he's just out
for blood. Okay. And yeah, he does prey
on females. And I suppose even in the
book it's kind of hinted at that maybe
there's you know I mean I don't remember
anything about him being sexual but if
you're praying on females maybe there's
instead of males you know so there must
be something sensual involved perhaps
but um the uh the woman Mia
is is not only is she repulsed by him
and there's no romantic overtures or
kind of mutual romance between them.
She's actually very pure, very
Christian, very devout, very pious. And
that's sort of, you know, why he why
Dracula is attracted to and wants to
feed on her because she's this uh
innocent sacrificial victim essentially.
All right. And that's an old theme, of
course. Um, but in the movies again,
what do we get? Uh, so Ro not only is
Dracula sort of a romantic kind of guy
who's misunderstood, but even Mia, they
they have this bond eventually and she's
in love with him and whatever, right?
Uh, that's how it comes out. All right,
so none of that [laughter] at all is in
the book. Bram Stoker to his credit you
know whatever he may have done to the
original character of Vladep which we'll
get into
he was at least uh um you know it's he
he was actually a devout Christian and
and the book the novel Dracula is has
very strong Christian themes in it. This
is where you get the cross, holy water,
all of that burns and terrorizes the
vampire Dracula, right? This is it's
straight from Bram Stokers's. Um, the
more pious someone is, the more
including with relics and holy images
and so forth, the more power that has
against unmitigated evil as embodied by
Dracula. Okay. Um, now again, think
about how that has also changed. Okay.
So um you know if you really watch the
old old old movies with uh what's his
name Bella Lagusa or yeah I'm some I'm
sure someone will correct me something
like that and um belosa
if you watch all those old movie the
earliest ones I guess from the 30s maybe
40s and they still kind of preserve the
cross thing. Oh, the cross, holy water,
the the name of Jesus or God does have
an unequivocal impact on Dracula.
But as the decades go by and we continue
getting Dracula movies, you start
finding that the draw the cross has no
power. Actually goes in phases. Okay, in
the very early ones, maybe in the 50s
and 60s, the cross still has power as
long as you have faith in it. Okay,
which is fair enough. Um, but if you
don't, it's destroyed and and the
vampire laughs at you. But if you go and
you fast forward to the la, you know, to
more recent times, generally the the the
cross and anything Christian is laughed
and mocked at by the vampire. It has
absolutely no power. Okay? And that's in
keeping with the times or at least the
minds of Hollywood and what they would
have, you know. So even in that uh even
in in you know what what fends off and
what defeats and what scares and uh the
vampire the evil Christianity and its
symbols.
Bram Stoker at least uh he he presented
it. So in short the Bram Stoker uh
Dracula novel is a very Christian novel.
Um it's very there's nothing he doesn't
romanticize being a vampire being a
blood sucker. the the Dracula character
is not sympathetic at all. He's purely
the antagonist. And the good characters,
let's say for example, Mia, it's not be
she doesn't reciprocate any sorts of
lust or love towards Dracula. Um, you
know, but she is a pure and virtuous
woman who tries to resist him as much as
she can, including with the cross and uh
what we were talking about. And u so in
and of itself, I find that pretty
interesting. that whole evolution of how
Dracula has changed. Okay. Um, from
being a monster just again like I told
you and you see this a lot in uh in
these old writings. Um, I already
mentioned
one moment.
I already mentioned Phantom of the
Opera. And another one we can put in I
think is um Frankenstein. I read Mary
Shel's Frankenstein also a long time ago
and again not a very sympathetic
character Frankenstein uh today he's
just again I'm just a misunderstood
being made up of dismembered bodies and
you know and everyone doesn't get me and
doesn't understand me and I guess all of
that sort of all of that goes with this
new idea that they want you to believe
which is if something appears bad or
evil it's it it's just it's actually you
you know it's deep down inside It's good
and it's just trying to overcome and
reach out to you and be your buddy and
just just understand it, you know. And
it's I find it funny that in the old
days these novelists would write it and
they would present evil, but it was
still evil in their minds and everyone
understood it as evil and bad, not
something to emulate or or romanticize
or heroise.
But now in everything
from traditional uh uh traditional
literature, let's say, the bad guys are
now somehow they're really the good guys
because society is just too judgmental.
Sound familiar? It's just doesn't want
to give them a break. It's they're not
being Christian enough. They're not
turning the other cheek, being doormats,
and letting Frankenstein and Dracula
have their way. You know, another one
that comes to mind and I recall is
Grenle.
If you if you recall, Grenle is a is the
monster from Beaowolf. Beaolf is uh
Anglo Saxon early writing. I think uh
8th century. I I might be wrong. But
anyway, the hero Beaolf fights against
the monster Grenle, who in the actual
poem is a monster. [laughter]
Not sympathetic. But there's an actual
book named Grenle which I read way way
back in high school short book and I I
don't remember it came out when it came
out 80s maybe or 70s and um the theme is
how Grenle this otherwise evil monster
is actually a a good kind of
misunderstood guy and if you could just
kind of like rise above your prejudice
because he's a monster who eats people
and just you know not judge you'll
realize he's kind of like you. He just
he just wants to be a normal guy and you
know but he was he he was handed a kind
of kind of um you know
he wasn't lucky let's put it this way
because he was born a monster. So
anyway, uh my point is I've been seeing
this for a long long time where
literature written in the 1800s, let's
say, or even before Baywolf is a
millennium before or more. Um and you
start and the there's there's a there's
a moral clarity in even literature. This
is good. This is bad. This is the good
guy. This is the bad guy. And we know
that because the good guy acts good and
the bad guy acts bad, right? Pretty. But
now that's too simplistic and you have
to be nuanced, right? And that's why I
think we're getting all this kind of
shift to always try to show you how the
bad guy is really the good guy and the
good guy is a meanie. So going back to
the Grenle and Beaolf often times in
these renditions and and you see this in
the movies too, they they carry on and
so now Grenle's again kind of a
misunderstood misfit monster who just
eats people and um All right.
Don't ask.
All right. These animals I can't take it
anymore. But
anyway, so all right, I'm going off on
tangents again and it's time to wrap
this up. So, um, all right, the Dracula,
the actual the actual book, again, very
black and white. Dracula is actually, in
fact, an antichrist figure. The idea of
blood, you know, he he drinks your blood
and he dams you. It's kind of he's an
antichrist. Christ sheds his blood and
he saves you, right? So, there's a it's
it's actually the book is very good as
as as a as a novel, you know, from the
late 1800s. Um, but the adaptations and
the movies, well, they have an agenda,
don't they? Like every movie made has an
agenda.
[snorts] All right. Um, and like I said,
uh, uh, well, actually, let me move on.
So, so he All right, let's now start
moving into um, the actual Vlad the
Impaler. So, as I told you, he tried
Bram Stoker. He did some travels. He did
a little research. He already had the
idea. I think his original the novel was
going to be called Count Vampire, but he
came across uh this character named
Count Dracula. And like I told you, he
he read enough about him to go, "Oh,
this guy was pretty ruthless. Let me u
make him the origin of all this."
But to be very honest with you, he he
literally knew nothing about Vlad the
Impaler. It was just a name and a place,
and he got the place wrong. Okay, like I
told you, Vlad is in what would be what
would be called Wakia, but he actually
placed him a few hundred miles, I think,
north in Transennylvania. And uh he just
went by in Draul, and we'll get into
that. Just means the dragon. And he
thought that was kind of cool. That's a
pretty nifty name. Um and we'll get into
the blood stuff, why he drinks blood,
because there is some some backing to
that. And um at any rate um
all right [snorts] so in short the
connection between the Bram Stoker's
Dracula and uh the historical fellow
we're about to discuss is purely nominal
and atmospheric. Uh it's basically a
writer's creative borrowing which which
is fine for a fiction writer. It's not
he didn't mean to present a historical
link and um in fact it was actually much
much later after the the novel came out
that even people were able to make that
link that oh he actually based vamp that
the vampire count Dracula was Vlad the
Impaler. It took actually several
decades for even anyone could figure
that out because he didn't explicitly
say it because he didn't explicitly know
it. And it was found out much after much
later um much many years after he had
died Bram Stoker and it was by um it was
actually by historians and so forth and
whatever. Okay. So let's talk a little
bit about who Vlad Dracula was. The guy
that he the guy that Dra the Count
Dracula this big evil monster that
dominates this season Halloween. Okay,
we saw a little bit about, you know, who
he was in the book and he was a monster
definitely, even though now he's been
romanticized and sexualized and
glamorized. But now, let's look at the
real original fellow that he's based
after, who I know a fair bit about, much
more than the than Dracula.
All right. So Vlad is he's now known if
you want to talk about him he's known as
Vlad. His real name the way he would
sign it was Vlad III Dracula.
Dracula was just a title and it was
taken from his father. His father Vlad
II
was a member of the order of the dragon
which was I think initiated by the
Hungarian king Sigisman.
And um it was an order of knights and it
was known as the order of the dragon and
his father Vlad II was a member of it.
And uh so actually Draul means dragon
whereas Dracula means son of the dragon.
So he took the name I'm Vlad III Dracula
son of the dragon son of the guy who was
a member of the order of the dragon.
Now, he's born around I mean, the dates
kind of are hard to figure out, but I
usually give the date 1430. Some say
1428, some say 1431, but let's go with
1430. And uh like I said, his father
Vlad II was uh so you have to
familiarize yourself with this term vo.
Vodode is uh it basically means warlord.
Okay? And that was a big thing back
then. Voy means war and vode means lord
or leader. So essentially means a
warlord and back in those days being a
warlord means you are the political
leader because uh you know that's uh
that's how you become a king. This idea
that we kind of have and you see it in
movies you know where a king is this
kind of ee soft you know lame guy that
just sits around and drinks and eats and
has abs and he's like a disgusting weak
person. That also is a bit of Hollywood
back in the day. If you're going to be a
king, you have to prove it. And you're
not going to get followers, uh, who you
had to be at the head of the war. Okay?
So, when I use this word, the voyid,
people like Draul and Dracula and and
all these guys, they were at the head of
the war, at the army, they were the
leaders of the war. And this is why
people respected them, and this is why
they became leaders of men and kings and
so forth. So again, I tell you this
because I think um there's this sort of
attack on the idea of monarchy and you
know, have at it, attack it all you
want. And one of the ways that they try
to attack it is to just show you that
every king is kind of this spoiled sort
of weak uh pathetic, spineless person
who just sits around in his in his uh
whatever in his castle enjoying his
whatever harum and and etc etc. But and
while there was that, especially later,
much later, closer to our times, in the
days we're talking about, no, if you're
going to be a king, you were going to
your life was hard, okay? You were
generally going to be at the head of the
war, and that's the only way you're
going to remain king because you had to
prove it to your men, right? So, I tell
you all that again as context for his
father and for himself as well. So his
father Vlad II [clears throat] uh who
was a member of the order of the order
of the dragon
was born in a very volatile time. Now
you have to imagine we're talking about
so you have the kingdom of Hungary which
is powerful and then you have the
Ottoman Empire which is even much more
powerful and in between them you have
little Romania or as it's mostly known
Wakia at that time and it was kind of
like a chessboard for both groups. uh
the Hungar while the Hungarians and the
Romanians were both Christian and
technically a lot closer still, you
know, as a matter of real politique, the
Hungarians used the Romanians as as a
way or or they would help um they would
help whichever contendant to become
voyid uh would help their cause. And the
Ottomans were even worse. They and and
they would uh the Ottomans, one thing
that people don't really know is they
really thrived on the idea of divide and
conquer. When you talk about the
Ottomans and you look at the sources, of
course, they were they could marshall
behemoth armies and they terrorized and
they were very ruthless as a war
machine. But lesser known is the sort of
minations that they actually would play
and how they would often um you know pit
various forces against each other. How
they would put Christian against
Christian um because they're the
superpower. And then you have these
various Christian principalities beneath
them. Some are resisting. Some have
given up and become subjects. And this
is in fact was the case eventually with
Wakia whereas Hungary still hadn't. And
um so then there was a lot of you know
sort of diplomacy and manipulation that
would go on and the Ottomans were known
and in my book defenders of the west I
talk a lot about this but they were just
known as masters of manipulation. You
know they would you know extend an olive
branch to this guy even while they were
instigating against the other guy and
then doing it so the first guy can fight
their guy and then they would once he
wins then they would turn him turn him
into an enemy. So it was a real
quagmire. You know, it's when you hear
about the balkcanization that was that
goes way way back. Okay? And you'll see
that when you read the books and you
read the sources, it was very fragmented
and above and beyond the idea of
Christian and Muslim. I mean, still that
was the general fabric, but it would get
so bad at certain times that you had a
lot of Muslims and Christians who would
um, you know, orbit the Ottomans because
it was safer and better for them at that
time. Um, until they got betrayed. And
anyway, I tell you all that again
because it's very important to
understand the roots of Vlad the
Impaler, Vlad III, Count Dracula,
because his father was right smack in
the middle of all that, he became the
voyod, the warlord of Wakia.
um through the help of the Hungarians
and but then before long after after
King Sigman died and he sort of was on
his own and the Ottomans were pressuring
Waka he became subservient to the
Ottomans
and in this sense he became a vassel of
the Ottomans. This is the father of uh
of [clears throat] Vlad uh of the main
of Count Dracula who we're talking about
Vlad III. And um it's interesting
because when you read the sources about
him,
you get this you get the impression that
okay, he's you know I'm a vassel of the
Ottomans, the Muslims, and I'm going to
do what they want. And he did. And but
he would always, you could tell, you
know, it was very heavy on his soul
because he would attack fellow
Christians as part of the Ottoman army.
uh because he had to because if he
didn't he'd be attacked. It was one of
those things and uh it comes out in the
sources, you know, how it just would
weigh heavily on him. Uh so he was
definitely in a very bad spot
and um and he would vacasillate back and
forth. So when he would feel that the
Hungarians were strong enough and they
were going to there's going to be a push
against the Ottomans, he would
immediately sort of turn his back on the
Ottomans and try to side with the
Hungarians where his true royalties
loyalties that is with fellow Christians
lay. And so at one point the Ottoman uh
Sultan Morad II was cognizant of this
sort of vacasillation going on and he
summoned him summoned uh Draul II, the
father of our character to court and
immediately threw him in prison, abused
him and was going to kill him. But then
he realized that the Hungarians now were
actually taking over Wakia and and in
reinforcing it with their own men. So he
figured, okay, I'm going to relent. I'm
going to give you one more chance,
Dracula. Draculi, the father, I'm gonna
send you back, but as a I need as a
promise um of assurance, I need two of
your sons as hostages. And this is a
very very common Ottoman practice, of
course, which you would take the sons of
nobles as a way of keeping them hostage.
So you can try to ensure that the nobles
do what you want them to do.
So Vlad uh Dra Yeah. Vlad II the father
uh submitted two of his sons he and the
oldest stayed with him uh in Wakia. The
two sons their names were Vlad who
became Vlad III our character Dracula
and his younger brother Raju and they
were then they and they basically became
hostages of the Ottomans. Uh so Vlad
like I told you he's born around 1430
and he becomes hostage right around
1442. So he could have been anywhere
from 10 to like 13, 14 years old. And
his brother was about 5 years old. His
brother is known as Radu the Handsome.
And we'll get into what all that means.
Um [clears throat] anyway, so they
become hostages. Very young age. They
start learning Turkey. They're they're
essentially in a fortress. And when you
read the sources, including what
secondary historians write, it's pretty
graphic stuff what they went through. I
mean, imagine you're 12, 10, 9, 6,
whatever, yanked from your family.
You're a Christian and you are thrown
essentially into a prison. Uh, I think
it was in an island garrisoned by Turks,
you know, soldiers who, you know, at any
moment are ready to kill you if you do
anything wrong. So, they spent years
like that. Um, this is important to keep
in mind once we get into the depravities
of Vlad the Impaler and why he became
the way he was.
and the father I was telling you who
would often vacasillate. So um you know
at one point I think at the uh yeah the
crusade of varna a big crusade in 1444
um he actually joined it against the
Ottomans. So he actually reneiged and he
even wrote in a letter we have it I
quote it um he writes and talks about
how I just gave up my sons you know to
join the Christian cause I hope everyone
understands I've sacrificed my two sons
because now they're going to be killed
at best
but lo and behold they weren't and
that's because the Sultan Morad II was
pretty smart and he still who knows what
he did to them all right maybe it was
worse than death but we know they didn't
die and that's because the Sultan was
smart enough that he wanted to keep them
as bargaining chips and he did in fact
use them later on. All right. Um and
then so eventually you know the because
of all this vacasillation and this guy
Vlad II's trying to on the one hand
appease the Sultan on the other hand
trying to appease the Hungarians and
he's always vacasillating and he's in
he's obviously you know between a rock
and a hard place as they say uh trying
to save his kids etc. He gets killed by
the Hungarians and gets overthrown. All
right. And um now at this point
um so at this point now you now the
Turks have uh Vlad III, our count
Dracula,
excuse me.
They had they have [clears throat] Vlad
III, our character, and his brother
Radu.
And now the Hungarians are taking over
Waka and putting implanting their own
men.
So the Sultan decides, "All right, I got
this guy. He's been my hostage. I've
groomed him." And he definitely groomed
his brother, Radu, and we'll get into
that. Um, so I'm going to trust him. I'm
going to tell him, "Hey, you can go and
you can conquer. Uh, I'm going to help
you take Wakia. And then of course, you
are my vassel like your father before
me."
And apparently uh the young uh uh young
Vlad III agreed and um you know he went
and apparently he was very young and he
actually did win over Wakia but he was
overthrown in like in a month and then
he just disappears and we don't know
much about what he did historically. He
literally disappears for you know almost
excuse me for like a decade
and then in 1456 he reappears Vlad the
third
he attacks um you know Wakia and he does
win this time we don't even know if it's
with the with the Ottomans or not the
first one definitely was but somehow now
he's older you know he's born 1430 now
it's 1456 so he's about you know you
know he's 26 27 28 depending on the here
and now he does become the uncontested
warlord of Wakia. All right.
Now, some things to keep in mind of the
context that very few few people lo keep
track of. I already kind of hinted at
how volatile that whole area was during
this time. And just to give you an idea,
okay, so there were 29 different voy
warlords leaders. Okay. uh between in
just 58 years between 1418 and 1476. All
right? So in 58 years you had 29
different leaders. I mean we're talking
each leader was less than two years that
he was able to reign before he was
usurped and killed. Okay? So this was
definitely a dog eat dog realm and uh
really does come out in the sources
including the people themselves.
Everyone was just desperate. Okay. And
and like I said, uh the Ottomans and the
Islamic Ottomans manipulated it and
exploited it as much as they could
because they were the super overbearing
power around these little Christian
statelets. Um but in and of themselves
there was just a lot of hopelessness and
just despair and everyone it was it was
like a doggy dog world. And that again
comes out in the this is why um
[clears throat] so for starters I told
you the Hungarians turned against the
father of Vlad III and killed him. Um
but it was who it was with the complicit
help of the Wakians themselves who were
living under Vlad and they actually not
only did they kill him but they took
Vlad III's older brother who was the
heir and apparently tortured him and
buried him alive. Okay. And we already
saw that when Vlad the third, our
character did the first time came and
tried to conquer and he won. He was
there for a month and then he got
ousted. So very very volatile. And
therefore when he finally came the
second time in 1456 and assumed full
control, he turned ultra draconian. And
apparently this is what you had to do in
this context if you want to stay in
power and create some semblance of
order. He created an elite guard around
himself, elite warriors. He was it was
just a pure military state uh right when
he um right when he took over in 1456.
Okay. And then the Turks of course
decided, hey, let's figure out what the
where this guy's loyalty lies. Is he
like he was before and like his father
was? Is he is he going to pay his
tribute and be a vassel or not? Um and
I'm going to read to you a quick quote.
This is from an important source. It's
all of this, by the way, is in my book,
Defenders of the West. Um,
this one I have a chapter, chapter
eight, the last chapter, which is all
dedicated to Count Dracula. And, uh,
actually it's one of the longest. It's
about 40 pages. So, all the stuff that
I'm I'm just giving you a quick summary.
If you're interested and you want to
learn more and you want the actual
documented source, it's all in there.
Okay. So, I'm going to read to you one
of the quotes that's in there. And it
says uh quote he Vlad defended the
peasants from Turkish demands by
refusing to pay the tribute uh once he
actually gained power in both money and
kind meaning grain horse. And he also
steadfastly opposed all Turkish
endeavors to enroll Wakian children in
the janisary core. So what are they
talking about? Well, they're basically
saying once he took over, he acted like
a Christian prince. no more. He He was
not like his father, okay? He was not
going to bend the Ottomans. He was not
going to play their game. He was not
going to offer them any allegiance even
if it was superficial. And he just
immediately um along with turning his
turning Wakio into a military state in
as much as he could. Um he also stopped
sending any kind of tribute, stopped
dealing with the Ottomans, and certainly
stopped sending their youth. The
Janiseries for those who don't know was
basically one of the Ottoman um
institutions after you conquer a
Christian realm including Wakia,
Hungary, the Slavic nations and so forth
was um you would go and through the city
now that the people have been subdued
and they're paying tribute and they have
no choice. You would go through the
little villages and find the healthiest,
strongest, smartest, best-l lookinging
boys and take them and you would take
them to the Ottoman uh court to be
trained to essentially be indoctrinated.
They would be circumcised. They'd be
forced to become Muslim and they would
be trained if they were uh militarily
capable to become jihadists. Okay? And
if they were intellectual, they'd be,
you know, administrators, but they would
somehow be taken to serve the um the
Ottomans. Okay?
And uh you know that's it's such a it's
it's such a diabolical thing and when
you read the sources and how the early
Christians described it uh yeah it was
pretty bad. I mean there's sources of
mothers screaming holding on to their
children and the Ottomans slapping them
fathers uh protesting getting killed on
the spot. Parents mutilating their
children so when the um the Ottoman
scouts come looking for them uh they
they just don't want them because the
guy's a cripple. can't walk, cutting
their feet off, you know, cutting their
hands off. That's how desperate they
were. Um, so this is what Vlad
immediately said no to. Okay, now that
I'm in power, we're not doing that. So,
Muhammad II, this guy, Muhammad II, also
known as Mahmed II, I I say this guy
because no matter what I do and all the
studying and research and writing I do
about history, he always pops up. It's
it's like the most dramatic savage wild
stuff always centers around his rather
long reign because he became sultan
Ottoman Sultan uh when he was only 19
years old and uh but he also died kind
of early in his 50s apparently killed by
one of his sons but he was around for at
least three decades and those three
decades saw everything from the conquest
of Constantinople to a lot of what we're
talking about now but he seems to always
figure prominently and he's by the way
one of the most uh beloved uh uh figures
in Turkey. And if you compare and
contrast what this guy did to uh you
know what western heroes who are hated
now did night and day. Okay, I did a
video recently about Christopher
Columbus and Muslims complaining about
him and um I compared and contrasted
Christopher Columbus with this Sultan
Muhammad II because they lived at the
same time. So they're contemporaries and
uh yeah, night and day honestly. So,
Muslims are not in a position to be
throwing stones in glass houses being
that they live in glass houses
themselves. At any rate, so this
Muhammad II
decided, okay, I'm going to test them
out. He's saying no to the janiseries,
the children. [clears throat] I'm going
to now for and this wasn't formal yet.
He just he knew it was time to send and
he wouldn't. So Muhammad II, excuse me,
sent three emissaries, Ottoman
emissaries to go and explain to Vlad
what he has to give them.
And uh it's a really noteworthy story. I
I discuss it a lot in the book. I I give
the sources, but these three men,
they're described as climbing up
something like 2,000 stairs to reach the
castle of Vlad because it was apparently
one of them at least was apparently kind
of high up on a crag of a mountain in
the mist. Pretty scary. Um, and they
climbed all the way up there only to
confront the void sitting in his throne
in a dark grim room. And they came up to
him and they basically said, "Okay, hey,
we want to maintain our peace. So
where's our money and our 500 boys? All
right. So they said basically you owe us
all you owe us all this back payments
that you haven't been paying since
you've come to the throne and we want at
least 500 boys for the janiseries.
And so the first thing that he said to
them, he just looked at them and said,
"Why are you wearing your turbans when
you're talking in front of me? I'm
royalty and you guys are just entered
into my home. you should as an act of
obedience or at least decency, remove
your turbans. Okay? And they said to
him, well, um, this is our custom, which
I'm sure he already knew, having lived
amongst the Turks, and he was just being
rhetorical. This is our custom, and
we're Muslims, and we have to wear it.
So, he said, "Okay, so I'm going to help
reinforce your custom." And he ordered
men to come and nail the turbans onto
their heads.
And so this is the first uh where we
start getting a glimpse that Vlad had
something of a dark sense of humor if
you will. Um and then I have this quote
here and then he as they were you know
these brain hemorrhaged Muslims wearing
turbans he threw them back into their
boat and he told them quote tell your
master not to send his customs to other
lords who don't want them but let him
keep them to himself. And they were sent
back and [laughter]
and uh you know sent back bleeding out
of their head to Muhammad complaining
about what just happened to them. All
right. Now to show you again, you know,
I was just telling you about how, you
know, the Ottoman power was not just
physical and and the the physical
component was definitely imposing
because they could marshall oftentimes
according to the sources up to like
300,000 men, which makes sense because
if you understand how the Ottoman war
machine worked or the how the Ottoman
economy worked, it was based on war and
plunder and subjugation and tribute.
That's it. Okay? That's not to say they
didn't have a mercantile class or
artisans. They did from the people that
they would conquer and they would profit
off of it. But as you know, their own
innate economy was just warfare. It was
kind of like other I mean that's not
surprising. That's like a lot of other
different people's Mongols. I mean
that's how they exist. We exist. Our
economy is we take your stuff. We
enslave you. And that is exactly what
the Ottoman war machine was. So when I
say or when the sources say that 300,000
men are were marshaled and today's
modern um you know historian just says
no that's not true. Uh that's not
realistic. Uh I don't know. It could be
because those 300,000 men had nothing
else to do but live for war. Okay. It
kind of makes sense to me. All right.
Anyway, be that as it may. So
[clears throat] once Muhammad's
emissaries came bleeding out of their
heads and complaining, instead of
turning to war, which he could have, but
because he is slick and cunning,
Muhammad II, um he actually turned to
guile once again and he had one of his
men who was a Greek convert to Islam and
there was a lot of those uh not just
Greeks but Christian converts to Islam
uh who lived near where Vlad lived to
send sort of honeyed letters to Vlad to
say, "Hey, before this gets ugly, come
you and I, let's talk. Let's come up
with some, you know, solution and I'll
talk to the Sultan so you don't so this
doesn't turn to war.
But of course, it was all a ruse. This
was meant for Vlad to go there and this
guy, this renegade would, if not kill
him, at least imprison him and take him
to Muhammad II, who would have his way
with him.
But Vlad, because he lived with the
Muslims in his youth, actually was uh
wary of what this, you know, supposed
honeyed uh invitation was. And so he
came prepared, including with his men in
the background hiding. And uh then when
when it then when it became clear that
this was a a false that this was a ruse
and they were trying to capture him, he
just launched allout war. He destroyed
the Turkish uh garrison that he was
going to visit and he captured and
almost killed and eventually impaled the
the the Greek um renegade that I was
mentioning earlier.
Um and then he gathered all and then in
vengeance outraged that you know his
hunch was right and sort of maybe in a
in a fury now that he's killed this
first group of Turks he went and rallied
all the men that he could wakians and
came back to exercise his full vengeance
on the Turks. And here's the old Russian
chronicle.
It confirms that Dracula after he had
rampaged quote for about 5 days in the
Sultan's land nothing remained. The
whole land was made empty and Dracula
drove others who were Christian onto his
land and settled them there. And having
taken a vast multitude of conquests, he
returned. What's interesting about this
is again here's here's a first another
first and very early um sort of
acknowledgment that this isn't just
about warfare and who's going to be
powerful. There's a religious element
here. He went he fought he destroyed
both the Turks, the Muslims and those
who were subject to them. But then the
the Christians that he could he actually
took them with him and tried to resettle
them in his own lands. Okay. Seems kind
of altruistic. Seems to have a sort of
Christian impulse to it. seems to have
sort of a crusader mentality and as
we'll see actually Vlad did see himself
as a crusader.
All right, but he was also ruthless and
we'll get into that and because you had
to be at the time. So in order to
impress the Hungarian king Matias um
Corvinus at the time and as material
proof he quote had the noses cut off of
all those living and dead male and
female and sent those no noses to
Hungary saying that as many Turks had
been defeated and killed as there were
of these noses. So he wanted to offer
material proof of his efficacy so he can
impress the Hungarian king because he
always wanted to get the Hungarians to
support his war against the Ottomans
because the Hungarians were much
stronger of course than uh the Wakians
at that point. All right.
[clears throat] And then um
oh and then and you know and as usual
he's he always has the the sort of
sarcastic rebuttals that he gives. So
after all that then he sent a message
again to Muhammad II saying that this
was the only sort of obesience that
Muhammad could ever expect from him. And
then he gave the you know the released
Turkish officers the following
instructions. quote, "Go tell your
sultan what you have seen here. I have
served him as far as I was able, and if
my service is pleasing to him, I will
serve him still, as much as it is in my
power." In other words, the service that
Vlad is referring to is killing and
chopping the noses off Turks and
Muslims. Um, so again, you can see that
dark humor at work. Um, and then the
chronicle goes on and says that in
response, Turks everywhere were so
terrorstricken that those who could flee
from the Balkans and cross to Anatolia
considered themselves fortunate. Even at
the Sultan's court in Constantinople
itself, there was an atmosphere of
consternation, gloom, and fear by the
awesome reputation of the Lord Impaler
as the Turks began to call him. Okay? uh
because a lot of those that he killed he
and mutilated he also impaled and we'll
get into that again. So um you know a
lot to be learned in this little segment
right here. First keep in mind the Turks
were the ones who terrified everyone at
this point. They're the scary ones not
these little Christian you know rebels
and fighters. Um so he just completely
terrified them including all the way in
Constantinople. And that as we will see
was actually the main point. A lot of uh
what Vlad did, all these sort of
sadistic things, the impalement
especially, was a terror tactic that was
required by by a weaker foe, a weaker
combatant, namely him and his people,
the Wakians, against this behemoth known
as the Ottoman Empire
and we'll get into that. Uh anyway, so
it was war at this point. Now, Muhammad
II, you know, first first he tried
diplomacy, then he tried to trick him,
and now, you know, it just gets worse
and worse. So, he declared war. Um, and
now his own people, his own Ottoman
subjects all the way in Constantinople,
today Istanbul, are terrified.
Okay. So, um, and be and and right
around 1462 is when this begins. And,
um, Muhammad starts marshalling one of
the largest armies ever to enter into
Christian territory. in this case Wakia
according to the sources something like
150,000 to 300,000 men again your
average you know modern historian
without necessar a lot of them they'll
try to make you think that oh we've
looked at the land and we've measured it
and we can't imagine it would not
support that many men more often than
not they're just guesstimating and
they're just basically saying no this
sounds ridiculous it can't be and it may
not be I don't know but what I'm saying
is I wouldn't be surprised when these
guys who are writing claimed to be eye
eyewitness sources and they say 300,000.
I don't find that necessarily very hard
to to believe in the context that that
is what an Ottoman did. An Ottoman was
essentially a fighter and a bandit. And
they had various levels from the
janiseries, the top cores and all the
way down they had these what are they
called? I forget their name but like
vagabons who would just come in the back
just to like lit vultters. Okay. So
whenever the time was right, uh they
would let them loose to just create
havoc and see what they can plunder. So
these numbers, as big as they are, are
not necessarily shocking to me. At any
rate, so Vlad at this point now finally
turns to again once again the Hungarian
king uh Matus Corv
Mateas Corvinus
um asking for help. And in fact, right,
there was a crusade expected. A few
years later, the pope had called for a
crusade and now, you know, here's the
Turks entering deep into Christian
territory. So Vlad contacted him saying,
"Okay, and and he and and the and the
Hungarian king had been given a lot of
money and and resources to prepare for
it." So everyone turned to him,
especially Vlad because the Turks are
coming into his country. And um and
here's a letter. I'll read to you a
quick letter that actually survives uh
where Vlad implores um King Mateus
Corvinus. He writes quote because by no
means do we want to leave unfinished
what we began but to follow this through
to the end. So he's basically saying
look we we the Wakians have you know
started a fight with the Ottomans and we
don't want to put an end to it. We we
don't want to just stop it. We want to
put an end to it the right way. We want
to defeat them and declare absolute
liberty. Okay, he continues, quote,
because we will not flee before their
savagery, but stand by all of the
Christians.
And if he will kindly lend his ear, the
king uh Matus, to the prayers of his
poor subjects, and grant us victory over
the infidels, the enemies of the cross
of Christ. It will be the greatest
honor, benefit, and spiritual help for
your majesty and for all true
Christians. Again, we will not flee
before their savagery, but by all means,
we will fight them. And if, God forbid,
it ends badly for us and our little
country is lost, your majesty will not
benefit from this either because it will
be a loss for all Christianity. Keep in
mind, Wakia is sort of a buffer ground
between um Hungaria, the Hungarian
Empire, and the Ottomans. So, that's
what he's referring to. So against the
150 or or 300,000 up to 300,000 Turks
that Mahmad marches onto Vlad's land,
the best that he can gather is about at
at most 30,000 Wakians, Christians. And
these guys are described as, you know,
you know, they're just shepherds, uh,
cowpokes running around and the the
weapons are rakes and, uh, farm weapons.
They have no armor, okay? uh against a
war machine that's coming for them.
That's how they're described. And this
was again the case um a little earlier.
The same sort of thing was happening
between Muhammad II and Scanderbeg in
Albania. And and it was it's very much a
similar story actually. Um
so they enter the Turks enter and start
devastating all the the the Wakian
lands. They started all the women and
children are taken captive. Vlad had
ordered to evacuate them and hide them
in caves and so forth. But a lot were
found. A lot were found because Vlad's
brother Radu. Okay, so Radu, if you
recall, I told you Vlad and his younger
brother were hostages as kids of the
Ottomans. And it was very very common
amongst the Ottomans that when they take
Christian hostages, boys, they would
molest them and essentially turn them
into what's called a catamite.
And we know this often happened. I
believe it from the sources it sounds
like it happened to Scanderbegg, the
great hero of Albania. But you know to
his credit he rose above it. Um and he
fought back and he never you know he
never lived with he never allowed that
to sort of dominate himself and become
overly traumatized because he knew this
wasn't his will. It was forced upon him
as a child. Okay. And apparently it was
also uh pushed on. But according to the
sources, the Turks learned very early on
that he's not going to have any of that.
And he was very violent and very savage.
They talk when he was a hostage, he was
constantly being whipped and beat. Uh
and and you get the impression that he
just and and it kind of makes sense. It
fits in with his character as we'll see.
Uh but now his younger brother, Raju the
Handsome, as he's known, didn't he
actually originally um actually I'll
read to you a little bit. I have a quote
about it. Um, originally
he was he also repulsed Muhammad II.
Muhammad II was a notorious pedophile
and I mean he he he was he was a
homosexual, bisexual, heterosexual,
pedophile, anything goes. I have a lot
about him in my new book actually, The
Two Swords of Christ that even shocked
me. But um, so he actually here's here's
an original source what it says. It
explains how Muhammad II quoteke kept
him Radu as his lover and maintained
him.
Um,
and it happened that the Sultan was
almost killed by the boy Radu when he
wanted to have sex with him. So,
initially the boy didn't want to
succumb. Radu, the brother of Lad. Okay.
And he continues, "This was when he,
Muhammad, had first gained the throne in
1451.
He lusted after the boy who was then age
15 Radu and invited him for conversation
and then as a sign of his respect he
invited him for drinks to his bed
chamber. So this is Muhammad II inviting
Radu the younger brother of Vlad when
when he was a hostage. The boy did not
expect to suffer such a thing from the
Sultan and when he saw the Sultan
approaching him with that intention he
fought him off and refused to consent to
intercourse with him. The sultan kissed
the unwilling boy who drew a dagger and
struck the sultan on his thigh. He then
fled in whatever direction he could
find. The doctors were able to treat the
sultan's wound. The boy had climbed up a
tree there and was hiding. When the
sultan packed up and left, the boy came
down from the tree, began his journey,
and shortly afterward arrived at the
port and became the sultan's lover.
20 years later, now we're moving up to
the time we're discussing where the
Sultan
Muhammad is invading Wakia. 20 years
later, not only was Radu Muhammad's
creature, but he also had a claim to the
Wakian throne, no less than his brother.
And he could promise the Wakians what
Vlad would and could not, which means
peace with the Turks. So very important
to keep in mind the role of um Radu the
younger brother of uh of um of Vlad II.
Okay. So he comes with Muhammad II and
he actually because he knows Wakia
because he was there as a youth. He
tells him where all the women and
children are hiding and they go and they
find them and they slave them and they
take them back to Turkum.
Okay. And all this time, uh, Vlad
outnumbered, is engaged in guerilla
warfare, he and his men. Okay, they're
just they're hoping to buy time. They're
hoping that Matias Corvinus, the
Hungarian king, true to his vow to
crusade and who had gotten all this
money from the pope and all these
magnates to actually go and help, that
he he too would. And uh so he kept
waiting. So he's he's playing this
guorilla warfare game now and just
trying to fight back in the middle of
the night. any any stag any kind of
straggling uh Ottoman detachment, they
would jump on and kill. Uh but they
[clears throat] couldn't really stop the
general beast from moving this behemoth
army because it outnumbered them by
almost 1 to 10. So now this continues
going on and on and and and he's waiting
for the Hungarian king and now and now
um Muhammad is almost near to Vlad's own
castle. All right. So, in desperation,
and this is probably what he's most
famous for, Dracula, he did what's known
in the sources as a night raid. And
basically,
um, he took a small group of men, which
amounts to thousands in this context,
and invaded the Sultan's camp, which
probably had, who knows, 20, 30,000 men
surrounding it. And the goal was to try
to basically decapitate the snake's
head, Muhammad, Muhammad II, and in the
hope that if he could kill the Sultan
and assassinate him, this large army
would just kind of, you know, crumble
away and leave. So, in the middle of the
night, he and his thousands of men just
like 3:00 a.m. came just barging in in
the darkness holding torches. And of
course, keep in mind, no um no uh no no
Muslim, no Turk was expecting this
because this is was very suicidal. And
uh they went basically slaughtering
anyone in sight, trying, you know,
looking for the most magnificent
pavilion or tent, hoping to find
Muhammad himself so they can kill him.
And apparently they got and and they
were led by Vlad himself, of course,
because he's the warlord.
And apparently they created so much
terror for the Muslims and consternation
that Muhammad himself ran off in the
middle of the night in his night gown.
You know this this imposing uh you know
sultan who was coming to conquer and
take over. He had to flee in the middle
of the night and um
and uh at that point you know they
killed many people and he fled. So they
couldn't accomplish what they wanted.
and a lot of their own men, a lot of the
walkins were killed during this
desperate sort. And then they finally
returned and uh you know the morning
came and in retaliation
u because he was embarrassed that what
happened Sultan Muhammad ordered as many
Wakian peasants could be found you know
the ones hiding and or thinking they're
safe because they're not involved. and
he got something like 3,500 of them and
had them all ritually beheaded and sawn
in half as retribution for the audacity
of Vlad's attempt against his life.
At any rate, they get to continue uh you
know marching unopposed with just slight
attacks from the gorilla army of Vlad uh
until they reach his castle. And it is
there, this is the famous, if you've
heard of it, it's called the um the
forest of the impaled or the impalement
forest. And basically what Vlad was fond
of doing is around his castle he had
apparently hundreds if not thousands of
his enemies staked and impaled and
surrounding his castle. Okay. And again
this was meant of course to be a chief
terror tactic and it actually worked.
All right. Let me read to you a quote.
So when the Turks finally arrived at the
castle and they saw this site and
realized that the castle of the impaled
was not just a rumor but a reality, they
quote uh they saw their thousands of
stakes of various heights which held the
remaining carcasses of some 20,000
Turkish captives. Their bodies were in a
state of complete decomposition due to
the heat of the summer and the ravages
of ravens and other Carpathian birds of
prey, many of which had made their nest
within the skulls and skeletal remains
of the victims. Barely recognizable
because of the higher stakes used in
deference to their position, were the
remains of the Greek renegade, remember
the one I told you, I think his name was
Ununice Beg, who tried to um betray uh
Vlad and another fellow, Hamza Pasha. So
he would that's what he would do. He
would put on a higher if you if you if
you had a higher dignity or rank he
would impale you on a higher stake
that dark sense of humor you know to to
signify your your uh your um
your uh status in the in the military or
in whatever the political scheme. Um the
tattered remains of their goddy
vestments fluttered against the evening
sky. The entire area rire with the
stench of death. the smell of rotting
flesh. Dracula had deliberately stage
managed the sinister spectacle as part
of his terror tactics to destroy
whatever spirit was still left in
Muhammad after the unsuccess on the
after the unsuccessful assassination
attempt um a few days before the one I
just read to you, the night attack.
Indeed, the forest of the impaled was
horrible enough to discourage the most
stout-hearted Ottoman officers who
witnessed the scene.
But Muhammad himself decided, well, I'm
already here, so we're going to camp
out. were right at his castle. And then
lo and behold, right in the middle of
the night again, Dracula with a few of
his men came and further terrorized
Muhammad that Muhammad finally said,
"I'm out." And he actually took his
entire army and left and returned back
to uh I guess Constantinople.
And um so it was it was it was one of
the most remarkable victories until this
day in Romania. It's seen as a victory.
However, um Muhammad again because of
his vast resources and power, he left
Radu, the brother of um the brother of
uh uh Vlad, who I was telling you, his
homosexual lover, he left him there with
a with an army. And now once again, not
to conquer, but to win over the Wakians.
After all, as the brother of um Vlad, he
he too could be a leader. That was one
of the issues with the um Wakian
principality. um they didn't have
primogenitor so it didn't matter if
you're the older brother or younger
brother either or would work and that's
what led to a lot of chaos actually and
a lot of infighting um so in this case
Radu presented himself hey I'm I'm a
good friend of the sultan and um you
know if you bow the knee to me all you
need to do is just bow to me and I'm his
friend and everything will be fine so
more and more of the Wakian started
turning their back on Vlad again
remember this is a very volatile time
and people are desperate and trying to
do whatever they can do to survive. Um,
okay. So now all this time Vlad still
won't give up
and he's hiding out and he still has
hope that Matias Corvinus is going to
come and help him out. He's hiding out
in the forest with a small group of his
fighters. And now Radu is in the capital
in Wakia gathering all the barars, all
the aristocrats to his side and
consolidating basically his power there.
And then finally, Matias appears and
thinking his savior is here, uh, Dracula
runs out to meet him and he's
immediately arrested. Okay. And um why
was he arrested by supposedly his friend
who's coming now to crusade with him?
Well, because supposedly the story goes
um Matias Matias had come across
intercepted letters that prove that
Dracula was actually a traitor and he
was working with the Turks and that he
was trying to kill him Matias. But now
when you look and I do in the book all
the contemporary sources
while admitting that that is the pretext
these letters they all also even even uh
the the Hungarian writers in the
chronicles say this was kind of weird.
It didn't make any sense. Uh why would
Dracula who above all other kings and
princes was was go goating and fighting
the um the Turks? Why would he actually
have sold out when all he had to do was
actually just agree to pay them tribute
and he would have been fine? Like why
this convoluted scheme? it didn't really
make sense. Um and in fact most
historians will say it's because
what had happened is remember there was
a crusade an official crusade and the
pope and um a lot of other magnates had
sent so much money to Matias the
Hungarian king so that he can prosecate
prosecute the crusade and like as you've
seen um this was the time when Vlad was
calling for his aid saying it's now or
never you know here they're coming into
our own territory help me but he didn't
so one what The main theory that I've
come across is that is that the
Hungarian king had already spent the
money and Muhammad had already left.
There's no need to go on crusading and
now he just wanted to sort of get out of
this whole thing and he needed a good
pretext and a scapegoat and that became
Vlad. So he imprisoned him on the on the
claim that Vlad was actually going to
betray Christendom essentially and
betray him because he came across these
intercepted letters and so forth.
And then and now from at this point and
so now this is about um let me see uh in
1462 this is right out okay so the war
is ending and um and uh Muhammad just
left and Radu is in charge and in 1462
um Vlad is arrested by his savior and it
is from this point on now he goes to
prison believe it or not for I think 13
years he doesn't come out of prison
until 1475
and uh he's born I said around 1430 So
he's imprisoned when he's like in his
early 30s and he comes out in his uh uh
what 40 something 45 or so when he's in
prison. But it is during this time in
his his imprisonment that you we start
getting all the horrific and ugly tales
about who this Vlad was, right? And this
is because again this isn't my theory.
This is what historians have said and I
documented in my book Defenders of the
West. Check it out. Um the idea is this
is the time of the Gutenberg press and
all the enemies of Vlad gathered in
Matias Corvinus's court including people
who had a lot of uh grudges against him
the Saxons that he had impaled but he
had impaled him. Even Corvinus had said
you you you you brought it on yourselves
because they had betrayed him. Anyway,
you get all these what we would this
would be sort of you know the 15th
century version of fake news. All these
new pamphlets from the printing press
come out. All these stories that present
Vlad Tempus. He's one of the earliest to
be covered in in you know by the
Gutenberg press. uh including with
fantastical and lurid engravings of him
and and all these uh engravings and
letters and and printouts are sent all
over Europe and they appear under titles
such as quote the frightening and truly
extraordinary story of a wicked
bloodrinking tyrant called Prince
Dracula. These and then these pamphlets
essentially become what's what you would
call back then instant bestsellers. And
no depravity at this point was spared
Vlad. Okay. The stories discussed in
graphic detail how he supposedly boiled
people alive, shredded others like
cabbage, forced parents to eat their
children, impaled and broiled, forced
husbands to eat their wives' breasts,
forced wives to eat their husband's
penises, forced Tatars to swallow their
own semen, built secret trap doors to
trap his to trap his victims and then
put cunningly put stakes underneath the
trap doors. Now, here's the thing. Most
historians have looked at it dismiss
these early stories which came from
Matias's court as obvious propaganda
meant to demonize Dracula and exonerate
Matus from, you know, the claim that he
had failed his in his obligation for the
crusade.
Okay, again, this isn't my idea. This is
just what most mainstream historians uh
would say that it's obvious propaganda.
And uh and you can see why if you look
at the very first German set as I have
that came out from beginning to end,
line after line, the entirety of the
text depicts Dracula engaging in one
vile or bizarre act after another. Uh
hacking people's uh ears and noses and
limbs and genitals off, blinding them,
strangling them, boiling, skinning,
roasting, and feeding people to wild
animals. And with no word of explanation
or context, he just does all this
because he's a wild evil sadist and an
immoral monster. In short, the devil's
son as the word Draul, which used to
mean dragon, now starts morphing into
the devil. And as you and as we'll see,
that's that becomes the modern day
Dracula fiction, the son of the devil.
Um, so, okay. So, just I guess a few
observations now. What do we make of all
these um you know arguments and all
these uh accusations against Vlad about
his nature, the impalement, the
cruelties and so forth. So I already
told you that by and large the stuff
that I just read to you is generally
seen by objective historians as just
okay this is propaganda. So what did
happen? Well, what did happen? We do
know I mean there's no denying the fact
that he engaged in graphic what we would
call very sad sadistic punishments. So
the impalement's definitely real. Okay.
And it appears he impaled more people
than others did. But that's the first
point that we need to look at. Everyone
sort of impaled. Impalement was a
general uh um form of punishment that
was agreed upon. uh even the the people
who complained about him uh various
Hungarian factions and other Romanians
and the German Saxons they all in their
legal in their legal documents have
impalement as a punishment. Um so even I
think uh Steven the Great who's a very
famous Wakian
um he used impalement and he impaled
thousands of people but more to the
point the real chief impalers so forget
about these Christian groups were the
Ottomans. [laughter] So once again Vlad
as a hostage learned impalement from his
Ottoman masters. We don't hear that. But
it was the Ottomans who really thrived
on and perfected the art of impalement
for very sadistic reasons. And that's
what he saw. So it's very clear that he
adopted these terror tactics against the
Ottomans because he was the outnumbered
underdog as I mentioned with the various
numbers
and he was just, you know, was a tit for
tat and he was doing what he could to
try to terrify and it worked, you know,
to a to a degree. It caused Muhammad to
eventually leave in shambles the way he
actually like ran away after he saw the
forest of the impaled the way it's
described. So it did work to a certain
measure considering how small and
outnumbered and weak Vlad was visav the
Ottomans. Um but even it's funny because
the things that were attributed to set
aside the impalement
put away the impalement. There's a lot
of other sick things that are attributed
to Vlad such as for example dining in
the m midst of his impaled victims and
there's pictures of that engravings
where you'll see supposedly Vlad sitting
and all these people are impaled around
him and he's just nonchalantly having
his dinner. Well, that actually was a
Turkish custom. So for example, after
the carnage at the battle of Varna,
which I mentioned in 1444, Morad II, the
father of Muhammad II, held a feast
among the corpses of vanquished
Christians. That's a direct quote I'm
reading from. So again, all the but you
never hear that, do you? Right? And so
I'll give you a perfect example. I wrote
it down because I remember it. Um,
so now that you've seen that it was
actually the Muslims who kind of
spearheaded and did all these things,
um, CNN
was had a segment that I saw a while
back, some years back about the Islamic
State and it said that ISIS, the Islamic
State, learned its sadistic methods of
torture and execution not from its
Islamic heritage which is replete with
this This is me actually or this is me
talking. CNN said that ISIS did not
learn the sadistic methods of torture
that we were being privy to what it was
doing. Burning people alive, crucifying
them, decap decapitating them, etc. They
didn't learn that from Islam, which
preaches peach, but rather they learned
it and CNN literally said from Vlad III
Dracula.
All right. So that again gives you an
example of how all this stuff in the end
does matter because it gets politicized.
All this seemingly you know abstract
history that you know whatever people
think we're we're beyond those times
now. Who cares? It's not relevant. Well
it's it's being weaponized as usual. So,
you know, today when we talk about
Dracula,
so we've seen the blood sucking vampire
and, you know, and his role and how he
has nothing to do with this, but in more
recent movies, of course, uh they are
now they do try to tie Dracula, the
blood sucking vampire, to Vlad the
Impaler. Uh I forget there's one movie
that came out maybe 10 years ago, I
forget its name, but that's basically
what it does. So, it's Vlad the Impaler,
the historical character, and then he
becomes a blood sucking monster for
whatever reason. Okay. Um, [laughter]
and never mentioned or never shown is
the reality, which is, and this is what
this is what I've been battling for like
25 years now. It's called context. What
I do with history is simply try to show
context. It's not that what people say
so and so did isn't true. It's to give
you the context of why that was the
case. Okay. Um, so you can say whatever
you want about the Crusades. There were
violence. Whatever. Whatever. You can
say whatever you want about Vlad the
Impaler. But the context kind of changes
it all when you realize someone like
Vlad was the underdog and that
everything that he did is what he saw
and learned from his abusers when he was
a child hostage and that he was fighting
fire with fire any way that he could and
that it was those guys who actually um
you know perfected the sadistic art of
dining amongst your impaled victims and
impaling your victims and all sorts of
other things. Um isn't that interesting?
But today, you talk to anybody who's
model moderately informed uh about Vlad
that the impaler and oh yeah well he he
was a horrible impaler and a monster etc
etc. And if you ask them well what about
the Turks? Oh I don't know
open-minded people I guess uh just
because Islam is moderate. So there you
go once again is um that issue which is
very important to keep in mind. So,
what was the real Vlad the Impaler like?
You know, I on the one hand, I wouldn't
want you to think that I'm trying to say
the guy was just a normal [laughter]
happy golucky guy. And no, there there
was obviously something special to Vlad.
He was very different in a sense. Of
course, everything I said does apply. He
was influenced by his childhood trauma.
Watching his son being turned into
basically a boy toy as it were of the
Sultan, the same sultan that demanded
his allegiance. I mean, little wonder he
turned so violently against him, right,
when he when he had the chance. Um, but
also seeing all the depraved, sadistic
punishments that the Turks would
regularly inflict on all and sunundry.
We have to obviously take all that into
account. Or how about the fact that this
guy spent a big chunk of his life in
prison.
So in his youth we he spent an in maybe
like eight years at least six to eight
years as a hostage of the Turks and then
as we saw Matias Corvinus imprisoned him
from 62 to 75 13 years. And by the way,
it was in in that it was during those 13
years in prison
where his enemies because during those
13 years in prison is when the
propaganda machine was talking about
what a monster he was. And then that's
where they also added that in prison
because he can't stop um impaling. He
looks around for bugs and insects and
rodents to impale them and kill them. So
that's where the idea comes from. They
actually said that. Again, your average
historian will tell you no, that was
probably propaganda. And the idea and
the fact of all this actually comes out
in the fact in in the simple um
development that
that [clears throat] in Matias Corvinus,
who imprisoned him because supposedly he
was a he was a a traitor, Vlad, after 13
years, he let him out because he needed
his help against the Ottomans. And to
prove his goodwill, his good faith, uh,
Matias actually offered one of his own
cousins, female cousins, to marry Vlad
and to be his wife. So that's obviously,
you know, the king is offering you his
own cousin. That's definitely a good
show of sincere intentions. Um, but now,
why would he do that if Vlad was this
lunatic who's just sitting around in a
in a cell, you know, passing the time by
impaling, I don't know, bugs and eating
them? Does this sound like someone you
want to marry to your cousin and form an
alliance with? No, it's because he knew
he was an effective warrior. And um so
anyway, he releases him and um a funny
anecdote I'll share with you is that
after he re releases him sometime in 17
in 1475,
he gives him he sends him to Pesh uh you
know to sort of rehabilitate and get you
know readjusted to being in society and
not necessarily in prison all the time.
Uh, but this kind of proved unnecessary
and Dracula was still Dracula just as
he's always been. And so, one one
anecdote is an officer broke into his
home, Dracula, looking for a runaway
criminal that he thought was hiding in
Dracula's courtyard.
Vlad instantly decapitated the official
with a swing of a sword. And the other
officers fled to Matias, uh, who got
angry and sternly questioned Dracula,
saying, quote, "Why have you committed
such a crime?" only to receive the far
from contrite response. Quote, this is
not what Dracula says. I committed no
crime. It's the police official who
committed suicide. Anyone will perish in
this way should he like a thief invade
the house of a great ruler such as
myself. If this man had come to me first
and had explained the situation to me um
and if then the criminal had been found
in my own home, I myself would have
delivered the criminal over to him and
would have pardoned him uh the man. So,
as you can see, uh, you know, even all
those years in prison never broke
Dracula. Uh, which actually is an
important point now to segue and talk
about his real character. And the best I
was able to gather from reading a lot
about him is that he was a very, very
severe man. Very severe, very draconian,
but very just. Okay? Which is another
way of saying, you know, he's the he's
the king, right? He's the prince. He's
the He's the warlord. If you follow the
rules as a man of honor, he's not going
to do anything to you. But if you
transgress them in any way, shape, or
form, yeah, he'll impale you. To him,
that will be just punishment. And this
goes to the idea, one of the most famous
anecdotes is the golden goblet, which is
and actually Roman, and keep in mind,
Romanians are proud of Vlad. They don't
see him as a monster. He's actually I
believe in whenever you the top 10
Romanian heroes or heroes of Romania, he
he usually figures among them. And it's
for this reason because he's seen as
yes, he's draconian, but he's so devoted
to justice. Okay. And so the golden the
golden uh goblet
myth, and I don't know if it's a myth,
maybe it's real, is that supposedly
somewhere in his kingdom by a well, he
had a golden goblet available so any
passers by can drink. And um obviously
that that's deemed insane because
anyone's going to steal gold, any
peasant who sees gold. But apparently
nobody dared touch it. And that's the
idea because he instilled so much fear
and so much respect in the Denisens of
uh you know his homeland and beyond that
no one dared transgress his rule because
they knew one false move and you're
impaled up on a tree. Okay. Um,
[clears throat] in fact, so here's a
little quote from one of the earliest
sources about him. It's the old Russian
chronicle of Afroen and it appeared
after less than a decade after Dracula's
[clears throat] death. So according to
it, quote, he hated stealing so
violently in his country that anyone who
caused any evil or robbery or anyone who
lied or committed any injustice did not
live very long.
Be he an important boyer, a boyer is
like an aristocrat, priest or monk or an
ordinary person. Be he the richest man,
he would not escape death. So feared was
Vlad. As for women, any caught in the
act of adultery or just being lazy, she
too could expect being staked or worse.
Okay, so I'm reading this now. So Vlad
was even ruthless um with those who
would not or could not carry their own
weight, vagabons.
And there's a quote. Quote, "These men
live off the so supposedly Vlad said
this, these men live off the sweat of
others, so they are useless to
humanity." He's talking about bums and
homeless people, I suppose. Quote, "It
is a form of thievery. In fact, the
masked robber in the forest demands your
purse, but if you are quicker with your
hand and more vigorous than he, you can
escape him." However, these bums and
vagabons take your belongings gradually
by begging. But they still take it. They
are worse than robbers. May such men be
eradicated from my land. And since he
was the voyoid, such wishes tended to be
realized. Okay,
so anyway, Matias finally um
[clears throat] releases him in 1475,
marries him off to his um cousin and
uses him to fight the Ottomans. And in
fact, Vlad starts making a lot of as
expected inroads and a lot of he wins a
lot of victories as before. So he takes
up right where he left off and he starts
beating the uh the Ottomans in the name
of Matias
and um all and finally he had to do this
before he can actually try to reclaim
his own Wakian kingdom. And finally in
1476 having subdued many of uh the
Hungarian kingdom's enemies he's now he
attacks Wakia his own former kingdom to
try to reclaim it. and he gets it and he
wins it again in December of 1476
until betrayal strikes him once again
and um he gets killed. The Ottomans
finally win. They invade his uh castle.
They kill him. They chop him up into
pieces and they set his head to the
Sultan Muhammad II. So according to one
chronicler an early one uh Jacob unrest
he writes he he he discusses that what
happened and because it's very if you
look at the sources there's different ex
different different logic as how he got
killed but most of them stress a form of
betrayal and especially this one which
is one of the earliest which I'll read
to you and he writes that Dracula was
killed with great cunning because the
Turks wished to avenge the great enmity
which he had borne against them for so
long and also the great damages he had
inflicted upon them. So they hired a
Turk, or it could be an Ottoman servant,
to act as one of his servants with the
mission of killing him while he served
him. The Turk was apparently instructed
to attack Dracula from the back. He was
then to cut off his head and bring it
back on horseback to the Sultan. That
much was certainly true because in the
end, Vlad's head, like I told you, was
sent to and thrust top the highest stake
in Constantinople.
you know, proof to everyone who was
terrified that the dread lord Impaler
was finally dead at the age of 47.
And so really ended one of the most
fascinating figures of his own lifetime
and as we can see uh up and up to our
times and how he's been morphed. So all
right, that's about it. I'm going to
wrap it up soon. just a few remarks
about, you know, one of the things that
does come out in the sources and that
you rarely see and is somewhat
suppressed
is the Christianity of Vlad. Yeah, I
read to you one of the quotes um that he
wrote a letter to Matias and he talked
about standing with Christianity and so
forth. And if you look in my book in
chapter 8, I have a lot more quotes
attributed to him where he says things
like, you know, he he discusses the
Turks as quote the crulest enemies of
the cross of Christ. And moreover, and
contrary to all the portrayals of him,
he was apparently very fond of hanging
out with Romanian Orthodox monks.
And he was uh you know, there's a couple
of monasteries that he was known to
often spend time with and in. Um
and he also when he would impose a death
penalty upon anyone, he would insist
upon proper Christian ceremony so that
his victim if he was a Christian would
get a Christian burial and um you know
he basically saw himself as a Christian
crusader, the son of the dragon who was
a member of an order devoted to fighting
the Ottomans. Okay. and he founded
monasteries and he sent large donations
to Mount Aos and uh he even quote
created a sovereign church in his
country essentially laying the
groundwork for a Romanian Orthodox
church. Okay. And uh I'm reading a quote
this should be recognized as one of his
greatest achievements as prince of
Wakia. Okay. And so as you can see you
know you don't hear this part but he
definitely had an interest in
Christianity. [snorts] uh he saw his war
and resistance against the Turks in
Christian terms like almost everyone
else did. Um he saw himself as a
crusader and um you know that that was
the sort of lens that he was operating
through just like all the other guys um
you know that I talk about in defenders
of the west for example be they you know
Catholic or orthodox or whatever. So,
you know, so yeah, that's that's him.
And until today, like I told you,
another reason that sort of validates
him is who knows him better than his own
people. So, in Romania, Vlad the
Impaler, Dracula is actually still a
celebrated figure. Like I told you,
often in polls, uh, appearing in the top
10 most liked and most heroic
characters. So, that itself should go
some way. I mean, who knows who knows
Dracula better, you know, Bram Stoker,
this Irishman or 21st century Hollywood
movie makers or the Romanians uh who who
themselves suffered under his rule as as
I as I pointed out. But apparently
there's still a saying amongst the
Romanians, you know, whenever there's a
lot of depravity and immorality going
on, they say something like, "Where art
thou Dracula to lay your hands on them
all?" apparently to go and impale all
these uh whatever um [clears throat] im
immoral people operating.
All right, I'm gonna end it now. So, um
the final observation, you know, we
started a little a little about
Halloween and I gave you the etmology
and how it traces back to Christianity
and we ended up by talking about
Halloween's chief denisin Dracula and
how he also ends up as being a Christian
hero. So, it's kind of interesting,
isn't it? uh you move to our times how
everything that starts off sort of noble
and good and Christian has become
emblematic of evil and uh in a way even
ex praising evil. Halloween from being
the the eve, you know, where you have a
vigil for All Saints Day is now what it
is. And Dracula, who was just a
Christian man fighting fire with fire,
the any way he could against the
Muslims, is now a blood sucker and
denisin of the night, who also and then
on top of all that, I mean, that goes
back to Bram Stoker, but at least he
would show him as an evil creature, but
now he's also sympathetic. Dracula, you
know, all these movies and series or
whatever that try to praise and glorify
vampireism and turn it into something,
you know, sexual or glamorous or
whatever. So, obviously there's a lot of
changes going on.
Um, and it's just everything that it
starts off decent and noble and
especially Christian is intentionally
being perverted. All right, I'm going to
end it there [laughter]
and let's take a few
chats.
All right, [snorts]
[clears throat]
Ryan. Hi Raymond. How much time do you
spend keeping up with the news versus
work and study? I don't watch the news
at all. Oh my god. I stay away from
that. It's to me the news is comedy. To
me, the news is what the powers that be
have decided you should be talking about
today. They don't care if you take a pro
or a con position. Okay? It's it's just
the gossip that we all are supposed to
opine about. And more often than not, it
has zero interest or relevance to me
because it doesn't teach me anything.
More often than not, it's a development
that I already knew was going to happen
because I understand human nature. So,
there's nothing shocking or surprising
about it. But when it's time for me to
write an article or more frequently do a
video, I guess I I do begrudgingly try
to see what people are talking about,
what what's considered important. Um,
but yeah, I stay away from the so-called
news like the plague because it benefits
me in no way, shape, or form. And I
think it makes me a little stupid. Um,
sorry, but it's really not news. It's
just nonsense and gossip dressed up as
news. [snorts] Remember remember soap
operas which were like for the board
housewife, the way it was presented, I
don't know, 70s and 80s. Well, I think
the news now is like the substitute.
It's sensational. It's meant to be just
gossip and maybe it explains why even
more women seem to be tuning in to Fox
News than men. Okay, so there it is.
Jason, I've got to ask. I'm probably a
very harsh critic of Islam. Think it's
the single greatest threat to [snorts]
humanity in general. Then I look at
Albania. Only way I can square it is the
old USSR rules.
Well, Albania and yeah, all the old,
it's not just Albania. I mean, if you
look at uh all the old USSR nations,
look at the really Muslim ones like the
central Dan, Kazakhstan, Usbekiststan,
these nations, and they're very not very
Muslim even though they are Muslim
nations. These are the descendants of
the Tatars who became Muslim. So perhaps
I think yeah it's that kind of cold
strong iron rule just doesn't allow for
the sort of you know they don't have
time or tolerance for any kind of crazy
terrorism in these places. You got to
keep in mind terrorism, Islamic
radicalization, all that stuff thrives
in weakness, which is why it thrives in
Western Europe and it thrives in America
and it thrives in any Western nation. It
needs a weak setting where people are
allowed to do whatever they want.
Freedom. Okay. And and this is why, as
you point out, Albania and all these
other countries based on their, you
know, communist Soviet history, which is
somewhat draconian, not liberal, they
don't gravitate towards that stuff. The
only way you can gravitate towards it is
you need that sort of leftist uh veneer
that allows it. Which is goes back to
the logic of why are the leftists and
the Muslims always handinand so close
because the one empowers the other and
the other will eat the other one alive
when the time comes.
Super sticker. Ah, thanks Michelangelo.
Would you consider interviewing Jud Saul
from Truth Nigeria? Equipping the
persecuted. God bless you, brother
Raymond. Looking forward to reading Two
Swords of Christ. Yeah. Um, just contact
me on my website and we'll see what we
can do. I did a recent interview with a
Nigerian um, clergyman and that went
well. So, I'm very happy to do another
one.
Coal Train, are you aware of the Zenge
revolt that happened in Iraq from 869
883? It was supposedly the largest and
longest slave rebellion in history, even
irreparably crippled the Abbassad
caliphate. I am familiar with it, the
Zenge revolt.
And I got to laugh because the word
Zenge, people don't know this, but um so
you know the N word, the dreaded N word
in English, there's an equivalent of it
in Arabic, and it comes from the word
zenge, and it's basically zingi.
So if you say a zingi that's the
equivalent of the n word black has its
own word is so sudan you know that
country which is south of Egypt it
literally means uh eswid is singular sud
is plural so sudan means land of the
blacks um anyway that was a little
diversion but yeah I am familiar with it
and it was pretty wild and graphic and
uh but yeah don't don't wait for a
sparticuslike movie about it.
Okay? Because this uh involves the
Muslim world and it involves black
people being treated like animals and
slaves. Uh you're not going to be seeing
that anytime soon.
Katana, are you familiar with
Yes. Odd that a globally designated
terror group can operate in Canada?
their Khalifa conference 2025 about
defeat of non-Muslim nations was
cancelled after backlash.
No, it's not odd. I mean, it's bad. It's
unfortunate, but it's not odd. And it
goes back to what I was saying, which is
sort of these liberal policies that
allow empower and force
and legitimize having people who are
terrorists coming up and sharing their
thoughts in a forum, right?
I mean, this is the thing that people
need to understand. Like this, you know,
Mum Dami guy who I'm tired of hearing
about. He's literally not doing anything
wrong. What's he doing? He's he's
running for office and people don't like
it. I get I get that.
But you know what? The system allows it.
So, you know, instead of getting angry
at him, I I would look at the system.
The system's allowing this sort of thing
to happen. So, maybe the system is
flawed. Uh maybe not everyone should be
participating in the system. But uh I'm
always for looking at the root source of
issues, you know, telling me, "Oh, this
guy is a bad Muslim." I mean, I already
expect that. Um, but why are you why is
your system allowing the empowerment of
this? This is the perfect example when
we talk about Europe and you get all
these Europeans upset about the Muslim
migration and they call it an invasion,
etc., and they're angry at Muslims.
Yeah. But in a way, no. Because this is
not an invasion [clears throat] and the
root source is not the Muslims. The
Muslims are doing what the Muslims are
going to do. It's your leaders who make
policies who are bringing them and
drowning you with them that you need to
look at. That's the the root immediate
source of the problem.
But I went off on a tangent. Sorry.
Cat Sunday, finally I caught this
stream. What are your thoughts on people
saying Christianity does not inherently
condemn slavery and the rise of
spirituality?
What do I think that Christianity does
not condemn in does not inherently
condemn slavery? So, I guess what you're
saying is that um there's nothing in the
Bible that says slavery is bad. Don't do
it. I'm not sure if that's a true
statement, but I think it is probably. I
I You're probably talking about Paul and
how he tells slaves to be content and
all that.
Well, my response is simply that, you
know,
the things that we find so morally
repugnant were just normal to most
people. Slavery was is one of the
oldest, most common, you know, just
taken for granted institutions
throughout history. All
right. We may not like it. And I I don't
I I don't think we should like it. I
think it's a bad thing. But, you know,
we can't just kind of project our values
on people from 2,000 years ago when this
was when everyone was involved in
slavery. So, the Bible doesn't say
slavery is good. It just tells people,
hey, put up with what you're doing. You
know, live live the way, you know, live
a good life despite the shortcomings and
what you're doing and, you know, deal
with it. Um, I know people try to spin
it as if saying, "Ha, see this is this
means the Bible supports slavery and it
wants slaves not to fight back, etc.,
etc." Or you could say it's trying to
teach people to just uh live live in
harmony and peace with their current
surroundings. It's a stoic element. You
know, you you you deal with adversity or
in this case, you're a slave. Well, rise
above it and, you know, be be a good
person. You be good to your master. I
mean, these are Christian principles.
So, I don't think uh Christianity
endorses slavery. After all, it's
Christians who abolish slavery. All
right. It just uh it it was more of a
stoic principle. I think
Kevin
got my copy of signed two swords.
Ah, Kevin, I believe I signed your book.
Are you the guy who told me not to mail
it because uh not to mail it now because
you're worried about your current
setting and your traveling? I think so.
And if so, I'd be impressed with my
memory. But anyway, thank you.
Cold Train, with what the Turks did to
Christians and their children, can
anyone blame Vlad for what he did to
them? Enslaving children then making
them fight their own people as
geniseries. That's demonic. Yeah. Again,
that's a very important point. Thanks
for bringing it up. And I spent a lot of
times talking about it. Um, by the way,
this is the book,
Defenders of the West. I have a whole
chapter on Vlad and seven other fellows.
Um, but I talk a lot about the
Janiseries in there for whoever is
interested. And the whole point is it it
is diabolical, you know. I mean, think
about it. It's not just it's one thing
to conquer people, but these would you
conquer you and then we take your best
sons, okay, intellectual, physical,
aesthetically, and we make them our own
and we turn them into jihadists and then
we unleash them back on you to continue
the cycle and get your other sons.
Pretty diabolical stuff, you know. And
um how does modern day academia treat
it? They actually call it they I've
literally they've referred to this whole
system as the equivalent of a
scholarship to Harvard. In fact, the
Christian parents were just pushing
their kids like, "Oh, please take my
kid." Because they knew that if the
Ottomans took him, uh, you know, he
would he would live in a rich setting
and a very he he would be elevated from
the current setting because they're just
peasants. So, he would be insured a good
life. You know, [snorts] he would he
would eat well, he would live well. This
is how a lot of historians now present
it.
Meanwhile, in the actual sources, you
get what I discussed, which is mothers
hysterically screaming and crying and
being slapped by Ottoman officials as
they hold on to their sons and fathers
fighting and protesting and getting just
struck down by sword for daring to
interfere. Okay. So, yeah, very, very
evil, diabolical, and it was meant
basically to bleed the Christians of
their best. I mean, think about it. It's
like it's it's a win-win. We take your
best and make them our own, and then you
lose your own best. Okay? So,
that don't don't expect that to be
mentioned anywhere in academia because
it's unflattering to the Muslims.
E Fance, thank you.
Thanks again, Eel.
A lazy prodigy. Never thought I would
stand with Dracula, but God rest and
bless and forgive the impaler.
Yeah, and that's another point. I don't
want anyone to think I am uh I'm not
trying to overly heroise anyone. Again,
my goal is to give you context,
background. I don't I mean all the men I
say this I say this in this book
Defenders of the West. Um I have a whole
section where I say basically you know
what these guys are heroes. I I call
them heroes but in the end they're
fallible men. So don't you can expect
all sorts of warts and bad things. You
know they're they're not perfect. Okay
there's something to them. They were
heroic. They cared about their
civilization, their culture, their
religion, but they're not saints. Uh
except for St. Louisie and St. Ferdinand
because they literally were saints
actually. But uh by and large, well,
Dracula certainly wasn't a saint.
Flippy Muhammad II sounded like a Zot
type of [laughter]
Oh, by the way, stay tuned. I have an
important Zut announcement to make. I
have a video coming out soon uh on the
Zoot. But anyway, yeah, he definitely
was a Zut type of guy. Actually, you
know, pedestriy and homosexuality was
amongst Europeans and Christians known
as the Ottoman or the Turkish disease.
It was a very very apparently frequent
thing where the Turks would, you know,
degrade and sexually abuse young
Christian European men and turn them
into sodomites and catamites. Just like
in our story, Radu, the the handsome,
the poor guy. He shouldn't have been
handsome.
Cold Train Vlad was always raising the
stinks, [laughter]
so to speak. No pun intended, huh?
Uh, Flippy Muhammad II ran in a night
gown. original Muhammad. May Zut be be
behind him ran in his CB's garments.
[laughter]
H to think this Zut stuff was out there
for so long.
Um and it's become so popular.
Moon Valley, thanks
Flippy. In Japan, there is an Egyptian
lady. She has a YouTube channel who
rallies against Islamic migration in
Japan, but says Islam is peaceful and
against preaching.
Okay. Kind of contradictory, you know.
Um, okay.
Me thinks that's it. We've gone on for
quite some time. And uh closing
thoughts, you know, like I I already I
already pointed them out, but just to
stress them, I just find them
interesting that, you know, Halloween,
even Halloween, which everyone thinks is
this kind of scary evil time. It's it's
all hollow's day. It's a it's a you
know, just like you say, hallowed be thy
name in the Lord's Prayer. So, it's the
holy day marking the day after which is
um All Saints Day, but it's been turned
into what it's been turned into. And
Vlad the Impaler for all his warts and
imperfections and frailties was a hero
still seen as a hero by his countrymen
who fought in the name of Christianity
against Muslim terrorists essentially
who enslaved and tortured him and
enslaved and raped and uh abused his own
brother and father.
and he did what he could. And now he too
is uh not just a vampire who drinks
blood, but also engaged in uh but he's
also the more he's more they present him
in the fictional sense, the more he's
actually a good guy. He's sympathetic
because he doesn't believe in God and he
hates the cross and um
All right,
get off.
never ends with these things.
And um
so
all right, good. I'm ending it. All
right, thanks for joining me. Until next
time. Um have a good week and take care
and stay tuned for Elzot announcement.
Bye.